he has zero weaknesses at all you just
dodged and just hope for the best
you're going go this backside have
someone out of your butt on me taught me
welcome to Socorro
[Music]
welcome to PlayStation grenade
today I am playing Sakura and it's damn
hard it's supposed to be the hardest
game of 2019 we shall see the thing I've
noticed so far the thing which is the
greatest if you die in combat in this
game you think it's over but it's not
what happens is you get the chance to
resurrect you wait for your enemies to
touch just turn round and do their own
thing and then you go attack again and
it's extremely satisfying
ooh new enemy type new enemy type look
the size of that big
let's get involved come on come on me
bro whoa we are a bit of a bellend
what's your move okay dog can't hit me
here mother this game hates me so much
it did literally nothing nothing that's
not this move now I know it now you'll
never get me twice trick me once in my
bar for God's sake Adam you celebrating
now I can't hit me here
you take new tactic don't then run
obi-wan Shinobi oh it's a kite let go
okay well that was fun sneak attack that
is a bull on fire how do you fight a
bonfire what the hell did
solitary
I'm on fire what do you do to put
yourself out there is no how are you
fire blazing flaming balls this time
girl this is good this is good this is
progression we're getting somewhere skin
itching the [ __ ] up you're done is he
dead see you DeNiro are you coming at me
now I just beaten the frickin 54 bones
about your friends nice spear I'm
feeling good about this game now
[Music]
this is nerve-racking this is my first
boss luckily she's elderly dance yes
granny I'm gonna put you in the ground
granny
this is me take a while I'm enjoying
myself I love this game not again no
this time
just died with a grannies my face yeah
no no not another grinder no I stayed
that way so many times coming to stay
happy don't get much stay happy don't
get mad don't get mad
no grandma
you know what I'm going to do something
else
[Music]
Did you touch play dead Mia dead
are you dead I don't know no is it over
please be over yeah execution oh oh it
feels good it feels so good and I've got
some lady memories for it oh okay and
the next thing that happens is I die in
the cutscenes now as well Joey
we made it to the top so something's
gonna happen here Oh what the hell is
that giveth runs and I can't run away
put down your work put down your swords
get bent let's do this broke oh my god
he hits hard
a bit of that yeah yeah
the hell is Robert have i missed part of
the story
who's Robert but the world that was a
big drop you can see our loot at the
bottom I got some beads got this nails
now Oh physics physics by gravity bit
hey are you okay down there oh look at
his head it reminds me of a Shaquille
O'Neal gang of monks gonna do nothing
nothing they wouldn't dare start with me
okay they will come on and monks I'm a
shinobi for god sake it'll literally
buttered me in a second under half so
the moral of the story wait for them to
move I won't be starting that fight
again it's exact exact zigzag zigzag
Catholic me you can't hit me
I'm shinobi I need to get this straight
my own mind so I view the magic Bell and
I've gone either into a dream sequence
of some sort of time travel and I've got
to hunt down three monkeys this is so
strange
don't run free hugs free hugs for our
monkeys
this can't be a boss fight that was far
too simple hi You cheeky little monkey
who's a cheeky monkey here we go done
and dusted
folding screen monkeys No so I think I'm
looking for an invisible one
so if you're an invisible monkey well
would you be I can hear them but just
that behind us just here haha I like
that that's a pretty cool gimmick well
please can we back to galaxy now will
you help me achieve this aim of course I
will my dog I'm gonna help Kuro father I
cannot break the iron code pardon I want
to help hero
help me let me help him I can oh that's
all right then so you can give me an
option but there's no option really
there ooh
friend or foe do you think let's go find
out
gorilla
so dinosaur he's a gorilla he looks like
great toast
is he gonna sword in his head so he has
a half cut off head nice disavow how the
heck do we even get close enough to hit
him boom he has zero weaknesses at all
we just dodged and just hope for the
best
you're going go his backside have some
of that up your butt did he just fart on
me what is this taught me well welcome
to Sakura know how much health does it
take off your entire bar holy hell
then again yep yeah of course it is that
I could even see and stupid camera angle
oh let's see so much fun go hard go hard
go hard go home this is it busy sticking
in your eyeballs
we get his head up before that took
hours but I'm the better man
monkey boy Kratos gorilla Kratos
execution I'm the grass still smell like
farts look I got the fart stench
[Music]